I'm about to experience weightlessness
for the first time.
Oh my god! Oh my god
that is so strange  *Oh my god*
this is totally freaky
this is way better than I expected
I'm just gonna say that right now
*um*
I'm going up to the ceiling
and here we are.
I am ridiculously excited, because behind me
is a Zero-G plane.
I'm in France, I was invited here by
by the youtuber Bruce.
This is Bruce, Diana physics girl.
We are going - flying some parabolas-  we're going into Zero-G
It's gonna be awesome! C'mon
The principle behind weightlessness is pretty simple,
the plane and everything inside it just need to accelerate towards the earth
at the same rate as a freely falling object in a vacuum.
That is 9.8 meters per second squared
So, you can think of your body as this pen, and the plane as this bottle
and when it's freely falling, there's no contact force between the pen and the bottle,
and so the pen feels weightless.
So you might think the way to do this
is just to put the plane into a dive.
But that's not actually how it works.
Instead, the plane starts climbing
at a steadily increasing angle.
With no windows inside,
it's impossible to tell that this is happening,
and all you feel is pressed into the floor with a force
1.8 times your body weight.
This is because the plane's acceleration is
directed upwards and perpendicular to
the floor, and it makes standing very
difficult - not only are you nearly twice
as heavy, all the blood drains from your
head and into your feet - which made me
pretty dizzy. -Ah!
Haha! So weak... ugh -Lying on your back is much
more comfortable, and we're advised not
to move our heads around and look
straight ahead,
because in hyper-G our vestibular system
is hypersensitive to movement, which can
lead to motion sickness. And that's why
this is sometimes called the vomit comet.
-I kind of like this. -It is fun, feels like
someone lying on you -Yeah -Not like that.
Once the plane is climbing at about 50
degrees,
the engines are ramped down, and the
plane is put into a parabolic trajectory.
It's at this point that you start
experiencing weightlessness. -I can feel
myself getting lighter... oh that is such a
strange feeling... that is so weird...
-The plane and you are still moving
upward, but you are accelerating downward.
-There's Diana, she's the physics girl
Then the plane peaks, and start
speeding up again towards the Earth.
The whole time the plane is
accelerating toward Earth
with the same acceleration as a
free falling object in vacuum,
the pilots have to very skillfully
adjust the thrust
to perfectly balance air resistance,
and maintain exactly this acceleration.
Oh, my goodness-
how do you feel?
This is incredible.
So, it's like throwing this bottle
into the air
the pen inside experiences weightlessness
from the time it leaves my hand,
until it comes into contact again.
After 22 seconds of weightlessness,
the pilots pull out of the dive
again, subjecting us to hyper-g...
as the plane accelerate upwards.
In total, we have performed thirteen
of these zero-g parabolas-
plus, one martian gravity and
two moon gravity parabolas.
Okay, we are now in Mars gravity.
In Mars gravity i can do
one arm pull ups..
maybe.
I am the martian.
We brought along some experiments
to do in zero-g.
So, this is in about 1g,
of gravity
this are what the flame looks like
on this barbecue lighter
now we are gonna try it
in hyper-g?
And then we'll try it in zero-g
and it should be...
We will see...  (2x).
We take it for granted that flames
had this distinctive shape.
But that only because of gravity.
The products of combustion have more energy
and so, move around faster and take up more space
than the cooler air around them.
Therefore, there is a buoyant force on them,
which is greater than their weight-
and so, hot air rises.
This helps pulling the oxygen from
around the flame to continue the reaction.
We are going through hyper-g.
i keep blowing out the candle, because...
The, uhhh... stress of hyper-g is
significant.
In hyper-g, this effect is magnified.
Since the effect of gravity is
almost twice as much.
This amplifies the difference between
the weight of the hot air,
and the weight of the cooler air around it-
and so, the hot air rises faster...
making, a longer flame.
Oh my goodness.
Look at that flame just...
in zero-g 'cause there is...
much less buoyant force,
to carry away...
And so, the combustion is not as good
you can see a lot of smoke.
coming off, of that candle.
And it's incredible.
So, we still have a gas flow
so this is why the flame
is not circular.
It is not a sphere, but it looks very strange.
In zero-g, the hot air is still
less dense than the cooler air...
but, now there is no weight,
and no buoyant force.
So, the flame doesn't rise as high.
This flame still maintain some if it shape,
because of the flow of fuel from the lighter
otherwise, the flame would form a sphere.
Like on the space station.
Where, it's very difficult to maintain the
combustion reaction.
because it's hard for oxygen to access the fuel
with all of the combustion
products getting in the way.
So, if you're ever unsure about what
the gravitational acceleration is where you are.
Well, looking at a flame is a pretty
good way of finding out.
I also brought along a slinky, to
try the slow motion slinky drop
but, in zero-g.
Of course, here i couldn't dangle
the slinky under it's own weight
so, i swung it around my head instead.
The effect, should be similar with each
coils stretch to provide the tension that keeps...
the length of slinky beyond that...
accelerating in uniform circular motion.
I wanted to see what happens to the
end of the slinky, when i let go.
Here we go, 3, 2, 1.
Did you catch that?
The slinky remain fairly stretch out,
and kept rotating at about the
same frequency as before.
Initially, i thought this was a boring result.
But then i realized...
the reason the slinky doesn't contract,
is because weight, was never part
of this equation.
The slinky stretched out in the first place,
because it was rotating.
And, since it's rotating after i let go...
roughly, the same amount of tension
is required to maintain that circular motion.
And so, it doesn't contract.
In zero-g, it's possible to have a stretched
slinky rotating in place,
without contracting
as long as the tension in the slinky provides
the centripetal force, it will keep spinning.
This just goes against my intuition.
Which is, made of course...
only had of experiences with gravity.
Being weightless, was an unforgettable
experience.
But, maybe my favorite part,
was how it challenged my intuition.
And that's the reason, we need to do research,
in zero-g.
I want to say a huge thanks, to the team at NovaSpace
who made this an unforgettable experience.
And of course, Bruce who runs a french youtube channel, e-penser for inviting me.
You should really go check out his video from the zero-g experience, and of course Diana, the Physics Girl.
Go check out her video on zero-g here.